thank you
[Music]
all right check this [__] out oh [__]
we're running into it all right this
these two chicks right is that the same
trick friends since they were children
oh sure oh cool I like a good story
right they're best friends since
elementary school something crazy
happened oh I was like what is that and
if they were they fought over a man no
they're the same chick and she's
pretending to be a Native American
for real so she's so she's Rachel
Pocahontas saw yeah yeah
big time Big Time huge time dude so she
is a um Madison
indigenous Arts leader and she has been
revealed as just a white lady
um early in 2020. what did she identify
as with one is that okay an indigenous
artist urged the owners of a new music
venue in town to change its name it was
called the Winnebago after the street on
which it stands many indigenous people
and allies let the owners know it wasn't
the best name for a white owned music
venue one of them was Winnebago means RV
or something it's like a mini a mini
motorhome it's pretty white dude isn't
it [__] I thought what a bagel was a
white term wow my bad dude I thought it
was yours Steve it took months right and
then the venues like [__] it we give up
all right we're gonna re-rebrand as the
Burr Oak
and then that's way labor and then this
person's like way more white I'm glad
the owners have decided to no longer
profit from the identities of indigenous
peoples I'm glad the name is going but
I'm not happy the institutions allowed
to be stolen the first place blah blah
blah blah blah that's this [__] yes and
then um they've the problem with it is
of course she's just some white lady
bitching about [__] again and and and
she was also profiting from the
identities of indigenous people with
this [__] job dude oh no what what
you know white ladies have
single-handedly stole the whole like
minority movement [__] that was like now
nobody's talking about like what's
happening to black Asian or nothing now
it's all non-binary white ladies that's
[__] at the front of the street I'm
like male
why stay out of this [__] what do you
think it is do you think you didn't have
attention anymore do you think it's
because their heart's at a good place
and they just no but thanks to them our
generation went from like impoverished
with the odds against them to being
privileged didn't one generation it's
really impressive you know um I think it
was Bill Burr that was like yo you've
been by our side the whole [__] time
don't be ditching us now yeah he's
talking about white men and white women
he's like don't act like you guys you're
benefiting from this [__] the whole time
and then all of a sudden now you're
discriminated against now you want to
jump down our fault
oh
so yeah this chick is kind of a big c
as they say
um
she's a big China a raccoon I just
what's the um so like when this happens
is none of the fault to the people that
should be vetting her a little bit oh I
mean you'd think right right how good is
it outfit it looks so good like you
can't even go to a Filipino Christian
Church Without everyone gossiping about
whether or not you really are Filipino
even if you're Cambodian how did you get
to this level I know how did she
infiltrate like how do you get unnoticed
yet noticed but also too I feel like
this group that she's in is probably
like five people so the fact that she's
willing and like yo I'm down for the
cause I wanna help cool yeah they're
like come on they're like we know she's
white but she's still 20 of our
population or she's gonna do all the
work you know what it also could be is
that in this day and age it's offensive
to ask for verification but then when I
was like in Oklahoma and I met some
white kids that had native status
like they had those native cards and
stuff yeah yeah oh you remember that one
kid I was like they're all laughing
about it because he was a part of an
Asian club and they're like hey guess
what this guy's he gets like uh free
schooling all this stuff because he's
native and I'm like really you you look
white a lot of the whites there have
like a splash of like yeah so if you
have a percentage out there it's
considered like you get all the benefits
and stuff so it might be one of those
cases where they just didn't question
they're just like what if like they have
that small percentage because like their
forefathers were doing some
Shady stuff with them you know what I
mean well she's like zero she's like
what
is
because it's in your blood but uh that's
only because yeah your ancestors were
like you know kind of pillaging and
wondering who's hiring who's hiring
because if it's a bunch of white ladies
hiring and then she comes in dressed
like that and she's and they're like wow
she does have a pretty good looking drum
she's Enthusiast yeah she got a
convincing hey yeah yeah that's a nice
Buffalo hide come on in can you shake
your feathers a little bit
well she does wear moccasins yeah
exactly that's it because then they're
going to stereotype they're going to use
all those stereotypes and be like she's
[__] high it's just nuts that like
you get you see these like different
programs that do such a bad job
background checking and then you
remember times where like you didn't get
a job at Sunglass Hut and you're like
and she got this yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah like I mean think about how Rachel
Doles all got in how did she I did I
mean no one questioned her Blackness
because she was kind of black passing
so in this case
passing she look like she's after the
after she dyed her skin got curly hair
coming around like turn it around if
she's not if she's not looking like
Dawson's Creek he's kind of in her favor
like heavily for each one yeah yeah yeah
she's in that low it's like blown out
and the other is like a dimly lit yeah
she knew what she did like yeah dude if
she okay the girl on the right let's go
the girl on the right but if she is on
the left no the girl on the right does
look a little better I don't know why
it's the same guys I like the dark eye
makeup I like it yeah she looks sexier
the one on the left looks like she don't
have fun okay so like the girl on the
right you're a complainer yeah the girl
on the right she looks
pretty dang indigenous
like really like remove the clothes but
like just skin like move the clothes
remove the clothes please okay I see a
naked chick she has a big brown eyebrows
she's native
that's the thing is like we're just
never in the position to question
someone like that you guys see that
video of the uh look like she could pass
Filipino to you
yeah
it could be a lot you guys remember that
she looks like she could be kalila's
sister yeah for real all right go ahead
no I don't want to talk anymore say it
the [__] video the black chick who
[__] snuck her way into the police
department would be a trans or a speech
translator or whatever yeah that's like
the same [__] about like how are you not
vetting certain people especially if
they're going to like put into effect
like policy change or like they're
protesting something that like makes you
change the entire nature of your
business or establishment yeah it's
almost like when that happens and
someone slips through like you kind of
don't get to complain about that that's
your fault it's it's yeah kind of like
if you like let this white chick come
through and police department can't
prosecute the freaking lady Tut Master
like it's just and also it's like it's
not like they could change back to
Winnebago now that this was like a semi
fraudulent like native indigenous person
who came in my buddy he
um he is a language like cultural what
do you like guy for his for his um for
his tribe he teaches all like grades
like um the language to you the culture
that's cool I have to ask him if there's
some type of like
tribe betting like if it's like wait
which tribe are you from like oh I'm
[__] Cherokee oh really and then it's
like do they all know like from
different like I'm Apache I'm this I'm
back was it like a database you know
even FEI hung had to show the seal yeah
so yeah it says here it says here that
she came in she came in they thought she
was authentic she said how she had a
tambourine and it just looked all me up
and up she said how and she had it yeah
I've also heard even guys in the
military pretend like they speak Korean
and go places too
stand up where he's all talking about
how he would go to the parade and all
the Indians were Puerto Ricans that old
Puerto Rican when I see one
I don't know maybe they were like when
she was during a bonfire she was like
everyone's like how was I supposed to
know that [__] looked like smoke signals
that's what everyone said exactly right
but also I bet this chick she knows her
stuff yeah usually though she probably
knows her stuff more than anyone else so
they're like uh okay yeah yeah dude I I
have to I have to point out that I have
no issues with white people joining
minority organizations thank you because
they probably know way [__] more than
the people that are involved because the
guys that get it who diligence yeah
they're like they're like [__]
anthropologists dude they [__] study
that [__] like I learned so much about
Japanese history from Jewish people like
that [__] study the [__] out of it I
learned about Kwanzaa from Rachel dolezo
see
Dan Carlin knows more about the Mongols
than any Mongolian person probably you
know what I mean and like you know when
I say like Chinese words when I'm
speaking English I say like the
anglicized way right like I'm like oh
you guys want like chow mein or whatever
like white guys that study the language
they'll purpose is like hey would you
guys want some tall men like they'll
purposely like say it like that dude
you're really into this sounds like a
white guy to me I bet he only dates
Asian chicks too I was just in Mexico
and I just think I don't want to sound
like a vacation Dad too much like a
tourist [__] who like got a little
book with the [__] translation so I'm
just like hola como estas I don't do the
little flares because I I feel like a
[__] a fraud huh
I do exactly it feels like you're making
fun of it or something and you know I
don't know that's not my jam yeah
but you know what though I think we all
need a bit of a white shield in
organizations just like that we just
have to we need thanks Steve uh yeah the
funny thing is that you would think the
community for that wouldn't really be
that big where you could verify it
pretty quickly and be like hey you know
this chick and I've never seen her in my
life what accent was that [__] uh
Chief Wampa Hoopa
dude South Park had this whole ass joke
where they were talking about like when
they're interviewing native peoples it
was just white people with feather in
their hair so good yeah I mean that
wasn't too long ago that that was still
like like nobody even batted it off yeah
yeah bro now you can't even be a Native
American for Halloween's no more I bet
you can still find it that sucks
yeah on Amazon oh there's that's still a
top seller top inventory they gotta get
rid of you know yeah
I think if uh Prince Harry can be a Nazi
I think that we might be able to at
least be John Smith whoa whoa whoa whoa
you said Prince Harry was it Prince
Harry he's not a Nazi he was a Nazi he
was a Nancy for Halloween Halloween
yeah yeah yeah he's royalty man come on
oh yeah he's royalty yeah Royal Nazi
you're right was he really a Nazi for
hell he was a Nancy with the armband too
what yeah he's a full-on yeah yeah dude
yeah he got a lot of heat for it
recently yeah really yeah that's why I'm
like dude if you could do that I feel
like you could wear a poke on his outfit
why are people mad that he's shooting
Taliban dude I know and he went into the
party and he's like is this ash with you
go
[Laughter]
and then he go in he's like where's the
punch yeah
[Music]